hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2017 american science fiction and action
movie called 24 hours to live
the movie begins with a man named keith
sarah being transported across the
desert telling his story to other
passengers in the car
when approaching the namibia south
africa border post a truck is queuing in
front of them but after a while the
group notices something is wrong they
are then ambushed by militia hiding in
the truck a female interpol agent in the
car lynne struggles to find a way out
for her in zara they successfully escape
not long after two men are seen fishing
on the beach
the old man frank teases the younger man
travis that no fish would like to come
to him because he has no soul
they continue talking and getting drunk
until they get up and walk up to the
shoreline scattering two bottles of
ashes into the sea
the ashes are the remains of travis wife
and son kate and adam seemingly killed
some time ago
then travis walks drunk frank home but
instead of resting he goes out again to
a bar
while enjoying his drink at the bar
travis notices two men entering
seemingly looking for someone he hides
in the ladies restroom while the men
enter the gents restroom then locks the
restroom door before opening it again
he outguns the men easily then while
wretching and coughing they explain that
they are from the red mountain and jim
mora sent them to find travis because it
is an emergency
going back to his seat at the bar he
finds moro already sitting beside his
seat complaining about how travis easily
disarmed his two best henchmen moro
offers travis a job to kill someone for
the red mountain which travis initially
refuses because he is on hiatus but moro
raises the pay as the red mountain only
deems travis the best man to do the job
travis agrees then he is transported
with a car while briefed further about
his target keith sarah who is scheduled
to testify on camera for the u n
investigation against red mountain one
of his protection team lynn bisset is
also on the target as she is the one
keeping zera alive
then a brief scene of lynn video calling
her son christopher is seen while lynn
is recovering in a hospital and
preparing to fly home from south africa
to hong kong travis comes to lin's home
in hong kong disguising as an old friend
of hers interacting with lin's mother
and christopher he learns from
christopher that lin is flying home
tomorrow then rushes to south africa he
approaches lynn at the airport lounge
instructs red mountain to cancel lin's
flight to hong kong and takes her out to
dinner the following day while he plans
to kill lin then already figured him out
and shoots him to death
travis wakes up to the voice of dr helen
a doctor in a medical facility
morrow and wetzler the leader of the red
mountain are there with him as well
they ask travis the location of zera's
deposition then wetzler instructs moira
to finish travis assignment to kill zara
and lynn
they leave and then the doctor prepares
to sedate travis with a powerful
narcotic but he retaliates as he does
not know what will happen to him the
doctor tells him that he has undergone a
procedure to bring him back from the
dead and only has less than 24 hours to
live shown on a countdown on his wrist
he takes her as a hostage to escape goes
to a harbor and calls frank through a
public phone telling him he will not
make it back this time
after that he hijacks a taxi and leaves
in a secured building zara is
interviewed in a room in front of the
camera he says that he was reassigned by
red mountain's top crew last year then
traveled through the night to a remote
container yard while bringing heavy
equipment the place was packed with
civilian bodies each has scars on their
chests and wrists they seem to have been
medically experimented on lynn examines
a nearby building from the window just
in time to warn the others about the
ambush by morrow and his team
lynn leads the evacuation of zera then
travis comes just in time to save them
using the hijack taxi a car chase ensues
but unfortunately moro successfully shot
sarah they arrive at the beach and zara
dies but lynn notices the memory card of
the camera used to interview him in his
hands and takes it on the other hand
moro's team only gets the camera but not
the memory card
frustrated morrow reports to wetzler
that the mission is incomplete but
wetzler reminds him of the big things
that are at stake
morrow gives instruction to green light
hong kong which means kidnapping
christopher
morrow calls travis through lynn's cell
phone asking to give the memory card in
exchange for christopher
lynn falls on her knees knowing
christopher is taken then travis calms
her and promises to help her bring her
son back
on the road travis hallucinates of
seeing adam his son the hallucination is
part of the side effect of the medical
procedure to bring him back
they arrive at an apartment where travis
packs his things then they leave again
to meet travis old friend amal
lin asks amal about the red mountain
turns out the organization provides
assistance in the region including
sanitation training and youth
programming lynn adds that red mountain
has kidnapped hundreds of refugees to be
used as medical experiments amal then
pays full attention to what lynn and
travis are about to plan
the red mountain abduction team takes
christopher to their base but sees a car
fire on route they ask permission to
re-route during the journey they
encounter lin and travis as well as a
mal's men
travis asks zack the leader of the team
to give christopher in exchange for a
pack of money but zach refuses
chaos ensues with both casualties on red
mountain and amal's sides
lynn frantically searches for
christopher sees a car driving off
chases it but watches in shock as the
car explodes after getting hit by a
mal's man
travis ensures that christopher is not
in that car because he knows abduction
protocols and the hostage will not be in
the rear car they quickly chase the car
that is carrying christopher and lynn
successfully rescues him travis
hallucinates seeing his son again but
quickly snaps back he bids goodbye to
lynn and christopher demanding lin to
safely deliver the memory card to higher
authorities
then travis takes christopher's position
and makes him get delivered to the base
by the help of a red mountain man who
survived the previous attack he goes
back to flashback of his past where he
was in the middle of battle with moro
morrow told him that sometimes the
people we go after can retaliate and
exclaim that kate and adam are gone
arriving at the base travis kills the
guards at the front gate and lets his
driver flee
morrow and wetzler notice the front gate
situation then morrow talks through the
front gate intercom to persuade travis
to hand over the memory card or red
mountain will kill frank travis
father-in-law
in panic travis tries to contact frank
but to no avail as frank is busy cooking
while listening to music
travis refuses to submit to red mountain
telling moro he only lies to him then
prepares himself to drive his car
straight away to the building he covers
the front mirror and drives in a
straight line saying this once for frank
despite being shot from many sides by
the red mountain the car crashes right
on the building stairwell
on the other hand a few men are seen
approaching frank's house hearing radio
sound inside the bathroom and blindly
shooting through the door however frank
is not in the bathroom he comes from
behind and shoots the attackers from the
back
he takes the radio then leaves
meanwhile on the red mountain base
travis carr that hit the stairwell is
making it inaccessible for the red
mountain to access
wetzler instructs another team to find
lin in the memory card the red mountain
men carefully approach the car ruins
travis is nowhere to be found but there
are bombs planted on the car and its
surroundings the bombs then explode all
the way through the elevator hoist way
and disrupt the whole base
travis silently appears at wetzler's
room takes down his henchmen one by one
while moro drinks casually travis
hallucinates seeing adam again after
being worn out from defeating the red
mountain adam says it's okay dad you're
almost home implying that travis only
has minutes to live but wetzler screams
for travis to come out so he snaps back
into reality and gets ready to face
wetzler and morrow after defeating
another henchman he sees the helicopter
to transport wetzler has arrived and
shoots wetzler's thigh to prevent him
from escaping then points another gun at
morrow wetzler says that travis does not
want to kill morrow because he thought
moro was his friend but reveals the
truth that moro killed adam and kate the
choice to kill was between moro's family
or travis family although devastated
travis finally drops his gun pointing at
morrow after a long moment saying that
he does not want to kill moro because he
wants to have a soul
moro comes to travis finally reconciles
with him and then goes up to wetzler
saying that wetzler does not know the
true line between friendship and
profession and gets ready to shoot
wetzler's head just then a strike team
comes and points their guns at him
morrow shoots wetzler anyway then gets
shot by the strike team
travis observes all of that while slowly
losing his consciousness as his wrist
shows he only has seconds to live
travis wakes up at the beach seeing kate
waving at him while adam catches a fish
and is excited to show him but then adam
runs away and travis hears a familiar
voice of dr helen the movie ends with
travis seemingly waking up at the same
dr chair as his first revival
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching